la línea 2 x + uno es tangente a la
hipérbola x cuadrada / a cuadrada menos
ye cuadrada entre b cuadrada igual a 1
muy bien si esta línea pasa por el punto
de intersección de la directriz más
cercana y el eje x entonces la
excentricidad de la hipérbola es tenemos
que calcular la excentricidad de la
hipérbola y para ello y para sentar muy
bien las ideas de este problema vamos a
dibujar la hipérbola esencialmente vamos
a dibujarla
a dibujar primero los ejes
está bastante derechito
vamos a dibujar ya no salió derecho
vamos a dibujar
este otro eje yo creo que puede hacer un
mejor esfuerzo
este otro eje mucho mejor mucho mejor
muy bien entonces tenemos nuestro eje x
nuestro eje y y vamos a dibujar la
hipérbola primero nuestra hipérbola si
nos damos cuenta como el signo menos
está encuadrada entonces abre es una
hipérbola horizontal verdad de hecho el
centro se encuentra en el origen el
centro se encuentra aquí y abre hacia la
derecha e izquierda
abre más o menos así
y abre hacia acá también
muy bien y por supuesto esto es solo una
hoja de la hipérbola de este otro lado
debemos tener exactamente la misma pero
reflejada muy bien entonces ahí tenemos
nuestra hipérbola y si nos fijamos qué
pasa cuando hoy es igual a cero es decir
qué pasa si estamos sobre el eje x
entonces si estamos nosotros sobre el
eje x es decir cero y tenemos x cuadrada
/ a cuadrada igual a 1 quiere decir que
x al que x cuadrada es a cuadrada o bien
que x es a entonces este punto de aquí
es el a cero y por supuesto también
puede ser el menos a cero muy bien
entonces ahí lo que tenemos son los
vértices los vértices de nuestro de
nuestra hipérbola muy bien y por
supuesto también tenemos algunos focos
bueno de hecho tenemos dos focos verdad
por ejemplo aquí puede estar el foco que
está de este lado que vamos a denotar lo
como efe cero
estará el otro foco muy bien entonces
tenemos también que considerar nos dicen
una línea que pasa por el punto de
intersección de la directriz más cercana
muy bien y el eje x y la directriz en
este caso pues son líneas verticales ok
eso no saben nada como una línea
más o menos esta línea
vertical
más o menos se ve como una línea esta es
vertical y nos dice que bueno que las
bueno además sabemos que las directrices
son verticales en este caso y tenemos
que recordar cuáles son las propiedades
o las relaciones que hay entre la
directriz en los puntos de la hipérbola
y el foco entonces si nos tomamos un
punto cual y un post perdón de un punto
cualquiera aquí por ejemplo este de aquí
este punto nos tenemos que fijar en la
distancia del punto a la directriz ahí
tienen la distancia del punto a la
directriz y nos fijamos también en la
distancia de este punto al foco
el punto al foco está vamos a llamarle
distancia al foco y entonces la relación
que existe entre la directriz el foco y
la excentricidad es que la distancia al
foco entre la distancia la directriz es
igual a la excentricidad que la
denotamos con la letra griega épsilon
muy bien entonces esta es la relación
que ocurre para cualquier punto que se
encuentre sobre la hipérbola y ahora
continuamos con el enunciado dice si si
esta línea la línea 2 x + es igual a 12
x + igual a 1 vamos a ver por donde pasa
dice que pasa por el punto de
intersección de la directriz es decir
pasa de la del punto de intersección de
la directriz más cercana y el eje x
entonces nos tomamos este punto verdad
esta es la intersección de la directriz
y el eje
y que de hecho podemos calcular su
coordenada porque aquí y justo 0
entonces sigue 0 de esta de esta
ecuación de la recta tenemos que 2x
a ponerlo acá 2x debe ser igual a 1 es
decir x es igual a un medio entonces
este punto de aquí es el un medio coma
muy bien de hecho sabemos ahora la
ecuación de la directriz de la ecuación
es x igual a un medio y además sabemos
que cuando x vale 0 es decir estamos
sobre el eje y entonces uno quiere decir
que esto pasa por aquí
digamos por este punto directo muy bien
este es el 1 y ahora nos consideramos la
recta que pasa por esos dos y que además
es tangente a la hipérbola entonces
digamos más o menos puede verse algo así
y que es tangente
oops
a pintarle un poco mejor
tangente en un punto digamos ahí
ok
entonces en este punto es tangente
y ahí tenemos ya el planteamiento al
menos en dibujos de nuestro problema
nuestro
nuestro objetivo es calcular épsilon que
es la excentricidad y voy a sacar todas
las fórmulas vistas en otros vídeos creo
que las hemos visto en otros vídeos de
khan academy e incluso hemos demostrado
las fórmulas relacionadas con las
hipérbola si ya saben que yo no suelo
usar fórmulas sin demostrar las sin
platicar un poco pero recordemos que si
hay algunas que pueden ser complicadas
un poco latosas pero además si estás
presentando el ite pues no tienes mucho
tiempo así que hay que dominar muy bien
estas fórmulas muy bien
muy bien entonces lo que vimos en el
último vídeo fue una relación entre la
línea tangente y la hipérbola de hecho
por ejemplo si si si nosotros tenemos
que la línea tangente de esta forma de
igual a mx más masa y le pongo se para
no confundirnos con con esta vez que ya
tenemos de la hipérbole entonces lo que
vimos en el vídeo anterior fue que
tenemos esta relación se cuadrada + b
cuadrada es decir la ordenada al origen
más esta distancia b bueno estos al
cuadrado es igual a la pendiente m al
cuadrado por a cuadrada esto lo vimos en
el vídeo anterior entonces además
podríamos utilizar una fórmula en donde
que se relacione en la distancia digamos
focal es decir la distancia del del cero
al foco y esto es que f cuadrada es
igual a cuadrada más b cuadrada
esta forma esta fórmula puede ser útil
para eventualmente poder despejar de
alguna forma manipular las algebraica
mente y llegar a encontrar el valor de
la excentricidad que es épsilon muy bien
además además tengo yo una fórmula que
me relaciona la distancia focal con en
la excentricidad y el tamaño este a muy
bien que es la longitud del centro al
vértice entonces sabemos y eso lo vi en
algún vídeo anterior de aquí de lacan
academy que f que es la distancia focal
es esencialmente la excentricidad ahora
muy bien entonces una última que voy a
considerar es la siguiente tomen esta
distancia que va del 0
a la directriz ya esa llámenle de esta
vamos a llamarle de muy bien esa
distancia ésta se puede calcular como a
entre épsilon muy bien a entre filón
a entre eps y long ok y la ventaja aquí
es que ya sabemos muy bien cuánto es
esta distancia y es un medio entonces
esto es un medio así que con esta
información que ya tenemos vamos a
utilizar la todita para para calcular la
excentricidad quizás tengamos que hacer
algún manejo algebraico de todo esto
pero tenemos que encontrar de esa forma
la excentricidad
ahora lo primero que se me ocurre es por
ejemplo sustituir esta expresión que
tenemos aquí en la ecuación morada y
entonces qué es lo que tendríamos que
elevar al cuadrado y sería épsilon al
cuadrado por a cuadrada pero antes de
eso quizás también convenga despejar de
aquí la relación que hay entre aiep
shilón fíjense muy bien entonces si
multiplicamos de ambos lados x por
épsilon tendremos a es igual a un medio
por épsilon entonces quién sería f efe
sería de aquí podríamos obtener que es
épsilon por a que es un medio de épsilon
y eso es épsilon al cuadrado entre 2 muy
bien ahora sí si sustituimos esta
expresión acá arriba lo que vamos a
tener es lo siguiente
efe cuadrada que es esto al cuadrado
tendremos épsilon a la 4 entre 4 debe
ser igual a a cuadrada más b cuadrada
a es un medio de epsilon entonces
podemos volver a utilizar esto y
tendremos que esto es igual a un medio
de épsilon al cuadrado que es épsilon
cuadrada sobre 4 muy bien más déjenme
dejarlo con amarillo + b cuadrada muy
bien ahora que si no sea a mí me
molestan mucho estos cuatros que están
aquí si multiplicamos de ambos lados por
4 tendremos épsilon
épsilon a la 4 es igual a épsilon al
cuadrado más 4 b cuadrada y ya tenemos
esta primera expresión en donde
utilizamos esto esto y también esto así
que vamos a utilizar esta expresión
amarilla para ver si ahora si podemos
obtener ya el valor específico de
épsilon así que ahora lo que vamos a
utilizar es esta expresión que me
relaciona acb m ya y podemos calcular
muy bien la m porque tenemos la recta
de verdad esta recta tangente que está
relacionada con la hipérbola y está en
por ejemplo de hecho acá tenemos 2 x más
ye igual a 1 si despejamos ya tendremos
de igual a menos 2 x + 1 entonces de
esta forma tenemos quienes m que en este
caso es menos 2 y nuestra constante c
que es la ordenada al origen es 1
entonces podemos relacionarlo con la
expresión amarilla y ya podremos estar
más cerca de resolver el problema
entonces vamos a vamos a ponerlo por
ejemplo
vamos a ponerlo por ejemplo aquí aquí
con verde y tenemos se cuadrada que en
este caso es 1 al cuadrado que es uno
más b cuadrada más de cuadrada es igual
a m cuadrada pero en este caso es menos
dos menos dos al cuadrado es cuatro por
cuadrada pero vamos a utilizar esta que
tenemos aquí a cuadrada es épsilon
cuadrada entre 4 épsilon cuadrada entre
4 muy bien y de hecho estos cuatros
ahora se cancelan y lo que nos queda es
que uno más de cuadrada es épsilon
cuadrada muy bien o lo que es lo mismo
si despejamos b cuadrada tenemos b
cuadrada igual a épsilon cuadrada menos
1 y por qué me sirve esto pues porque
aquí tengo
aquí tenemos esta expresión que utiliza
al ave cuadrada verdad y puedo
simplemente sustituirlo
vamos a hacerlo vamos a hacerlo ya casi
estamos llegando al final del problema
tenemos si sustituimos en esta ecuación
ave cuadrada que ya sabemos quienes
tendremos épsilon a la 4 es igual a
épsilon cuadrada más 4 b cuadrada pero b
cuadrada es épsilon cuadrada menos 14
épsilon voy a ponerlo incluso así 4
épsilon cuadrada menos 1 y que si por
ejemplo por ejemplo podemos usar la
propiedad distributiva esto es épsilon
cuadrada más 4 épsilon cuadrada menos 4
muy bien y esto es otra vez épsilon a la
4 entonces lo que podemos hacer es pasar
todo el lado izquierdo pero si nos damos
cuenta este término y este término es 5
épsilon cuadrada muy bien y entonces lo
vamos a pasar del otro lado con signo
negativo
entonces vamos a restar 5 épsilon
cuadrada muy bien
- bueno si aquí tenemos menos 4 sumamos
4 de ambos lados y nos queda esta
ecuación que si la vez con mucho detalle
pues esencialmente es un polinomio si de
orden 4 que hay que resolver pero pero
si nos damos cuenta podremos verlo la
variable como épsilon cuadrada y aquí
está épsilon cuadrada al cuadrado
épsilon cuadrada y así sucesivamente
verdad otra cosa que podemos hacer es
factorizar lo esto lo podemos factorizar
porque dos números que multiplicados me
den 4 y sumados menos 5 pues es menos 4
y menos 1 entonces esto lo puedo
factorizar como épsilon cuadrada menos 4
que multiplica a épsilon cuadrada menos
1 y esto es igual a 0 muy bien igual si
si esto a lo mejor te confunde sobre
todo por el por el exponente de épsilon
de chilón lo que uno puede hacer es por
ejemplo decir sea igual a épsilon
cuadrada y esto al sustituirlo nos queda
algo como cuadrada menos 54 que es lo
que podemos resolver y esencialmente
llegamos a esta expresión también
podrías utilizar la fórmula general de
las ecuaciones cuadráticas en fin ahora
tenemos este producto que es cero
entonces cada uno de ellos o al menos
uno de ellos tiene que ser cero entonces
puede que épsilon cuadrada menos 4 sea
igual a 0 o bien épsilon cuadrada menos
1 sea igual a cero si esto pasa
tendremos épsilon cuadrada igual a 4 o
lo que es lo mismo épsilon es más o
menos 2 y ahora si si fuera esto
tendríamos épsilon cuadrada igual a 1 o
bien
épsilon igual a más o menos 1 entonces
sin saber que fuera la épsilon que es la
excentricidad podríamos aquí ya dar esta
respuesta sin embargo la clave para
terminar este problema es decir que la
excentricidad
de cualquiera de cualquier hipérbola es
siempre más grande estricto que uno
entonces de nuestras cuatro opciones
tenemos más dos menos dos más uno y
menos uno solo hay una única opción una
única opción que es más grande que uno y
es dos así que ya hemos resuelto el
problema porque la excentricidad de esta
hipérbola es exactamente 2